duas histórias primeira história numa
tarde de verão é resolvido apanhar sol
como eu quero ser de repente comecei a
pensar uma formiga e no esforço que ela
teria de fazer para traçar o jardim
na verdade eu estava interessado em
saber o que é que o chez metros
representava uma formiga minha visão eu
tenho estado nessa manhã a ver o filme a
crise inclui as crianças como o filho
devia ter saído há 60 anos e crianças
até o momento já que jogava formiga
naquela tentativa 2 atravessar aquela
grande floresta de relva e é exatamente
nesse momento que eu pensei em criar uma
nos perguntar pro visual onde pudessem
ensaiar a enfim em tom de brincadeira
uma determinada visão que eu tenho sobre
o mundo e assim nasceu a série deus
jardim que eu tive o privilégio de por
aqui na biblioteca 1070 2060 sua
história
assim a minha mulher ela tem um armário
é antigo boliche e peças de da rosa
ramalho e ativistas cristo jesus um
pouco torto é uma vez estávamos em star
wars e compramos uma peça do bar
tradicional que é a primavera e quando
chegamos a casa ela estava a arrumar
aquela peça no meio das outras eo nosso
olhar e começa a ver aquelas figuras tão
portuguesas tão belas sai do mesmo modo
criar uma espécie de um tapa no visual
sobre a minha visão do mundo português e
assim michel é a série viva portugal
estas duas histórias banais ilustrou o
meu processo criativo como tentará
explicar é mais à frente quando
convidaram para vir falar sobre
criatividade a primeira coisa que fiz
foi ir a neta
é pesquisar o que é que eu te
conferencista exteriores russo que
existem porque é isso que com o mesmo de
um de ouvir pra que é trazer uma
determinada visão sobre tirado a ouvir
pra que ficar citações é determinante
sol o importante é que a concessão que
criaria aquilo o que eu já poderia ter
dito e então eles nesse caso não teria
muito mais a acrescentar
por isso o movimento vem aqui falar
sobre o meu processo criativo como
artista visual e sim também vou citar a
a algumas frases de de custos começa por
falar do picasso que dizia que não
procurava descobrir o vygotsky e foi
aqui processo criativo é acionado quando
se pretende que combinaram a construir
algo a partir do que já existe e por
isso o processo criativo envolve a
observação colha a escolha é a
construção e combinação pessoal
o francisco anda ou dizer que a ideia é
mais a oficina coisa na pintura que se
pode imaginar dos entendimentos mas não
faz do que explicar o genus no seu
processo criativo poético
voltando aos deuses já nenê é óbvio que
a criação desta série e girou à volta da
educação determinado do mundo como já
expliquei isso é que o clique
por um lado teve origem em que os
pequenos pensamentos daquela daquela
tarde os pensamentos a volta do também
jardim dos animais que lá viviam a do
filme que eu tinha visto naquela manhã o
que aconteceu verdadeiramente importante
foi a validação das duas das
significações e que os procedimentos
naquele instante
ou seja é não funcionar no processo
imaginativo
tudo que eu vou tomar uma decisão foi
criar uma série
é é cliente pois configurou num
dispositivo simbólico fala a de é afirma
que a criatividade e imaginação e oa
criativo devem ser preenchidos com
comissão
pelo sim pelo 55 ações que trazem como
ético pela significação trazem as suas
impressões das suas realidades
é quando pré fã descumpriu ordem pôr os
olhos ainda direção é o conjunto
processos cognitivos que permita o cj
combinação ea combinação de imagens é é
a organização ea realização de imagens
a combinação de recombinação símbolos
como para a criação de metáforas e
negativas e se um civic do fala além do
iphone é porque me ajudava a função aos
10 jardim e gostar óbvio portugal é eu
já um fundo tentava imaginar a
desenvolver é uma 11 uma força no fundo
e tenta tentava fazer uma reflexão sobre
as estruturas das sociedades humanas e
100 anos com algum humor uma narrativa é
a reforma do dispositivo simbólico e de
lá e agora já estou aqui podendo ser
certo modo orientar e o meu processo
criativo centro no sentido de que o e
coxim em coxim momento e no sentido do
iedi penning é de tornar o espartilho de
toda a minha estratégia convencional ou
seja voltar às palavras do vygotsky
observai recolhi escolhi construir e
combinar dentro do fundo os parâmetros
da minha estratégia pessoal em relação à
que o click no meu caso é que o que eu
falei daqui comenta a decisão é no meu
caso eu eu o meu como criativo opera
sempre que se conhece em determinadas
condições dos quais são e decisão e que
são frutas características da minha vida
unidade enquanto artista enquanto ser
humano
protásio também acho que essas
características individuais é é consigo
explicar naquilo que eu chamo o meu
roteiro de intenções que e isso teria
intenções é terminantemente no fundo
para a á a consagração do momento
crítico mas ao mesmo tempo também
escreveu que é no fundo e alguns pressa
é a vontade ea determinação que eu
peguei me manifestar
isso chama perder intenções no fundo é
uma imensa plataforma onde estão todas
as opções que eu fui me olhando
estão à espera
entendo que vivemos basto imenso manto
da lista
por isso enquanto artista é tentar
sempre reinventando imaginando a cenário
já dispositivos onde possa dar certo
modo é é esse aí as negativas que propõe
por outro lado quem sempre situar é a
minha representação simbólica numa
desconstrução e reconstrução através da
simulação do mundo real rodoviária diz
que é simular e fingir ter planos têm
eles também que toda ação humana é
singular e consequentemente a a toda
ação artística é simular eu entendo que
a arte e principalmente a arte do início
deste século se torna definitivamente
número viário da compreensão da
incompreensão do mundo também têm às
vezes exceção do que vivo é um grande
pacto climático composto de infinitos
outros parques temáticos como os outros
flex de uma sala de provas de roupa
a propósito parques temáticos hoya diz
que
max na tucson e grid é não encontra o
soe é preciso estar aqui é um sonho diz
partes mate que são livres
contemporâneos que como a maioria dos
planos pós modernos cruzou fronteiras
normalmente para os tintos campos da
cultura de comidas de um dia e da
política e da filosofia
por isso é assim tento no fundo é
estruturar os meus positivos simbólicos
como parques temáticos e incensados uma
turma nem ter reflexão sobre a
utilização dos vários judeus e
artísticos das suas funções e do showbiz
consegue ver portugal
o frango devolvidas ao criativo
aconteceu no momento em que estou a
olhar para minha mulher e ela está no
fundo ele arrumar as peças exatamente
que dado moto para a criação dessa série
em que haja novamente pegando nas
palavras de vygotsky officer vai
recolher
escolhi construir e combinar e dentro em
fundo dos limites da minha estratégia em
off também que esta série ela própria
também uma espécie parte matiko é sobre
o o o avisaram que eu tenho do mundo
português mas com uma particularidade é
que é o foco que eu dou o design a isso
das peças das figuras-chave já há algum
tempo em que andava interessado no
design ingênua das figuras do banco
popular português na negociação que os
que os artistas dão aquela naquela
formação que as peças techcrunch da
imensa piada mas também estava
interessado na ação que o olímpico
principalmente de trani dão as entidades
do maravilhoso e por isso não terminar
momento pensei que poderia também criar
uma outra metáfora visual sobre a minha
visão do mundo ano ampliando negativas
entre vocações da energética do bairro
popular português
evocações dessas imagens ligadas às pós
contas traz por isso é é a série fifa
portugal vinte anos depois evoluiu para
a série
o spurs teve aqui outras coisas que eu
estaria aqui também do falar
hum online diz que a criatividade
artística é uma forma de pensamento é
incrível perceber e pensará o são atos
que se encontram e se provavelmente
interligados a uma pessoa que pinta que
dança compõem o escreve pensa que o
chute e eu encontrar artista tem a
obrigação de conservar um sido no
sentido em que tem sempre que as minhas
séries implica em algum algum jogo
reflexivo
ou seja é eu entendo o processo criativo
como a construção de um canteiro de
vivências e e acredito que entre essa
ortiz tica que a criação artística é
produtora de conhecimento em história da
arte a cheia de exemplos
independentemente das épocas e de tios
df
vou acabar com última história em 2011
no âmbito do do projeto a 60 é fiz uma
instalação na galeria é a nossa senhora
do ano ea minha intervenção foi a não
for fechada da galeria que a merda de
consagrada grandes cartazes negros
corpos branco
eu tenho estado um ano assim a corda é e
este fundo foi a finalização do trabalho
o agente também em um jovem finalista de
belas artes onde estavam me ajudar mas
por cima mais para baixo nas páginas e
mais páginas um treinamento logo a
princípio estava em cima dos calotes
para e e e segurando o hol é da cola na
mão olhou pra traz e diz
é por isso que eu acho que aqui não
serve pra nada e entretenimento naquele
momento eu fui projetado pelo filme do
godard é eu ter isolada que a frase o
formulário com tais eventos dentro do
jogo de um de um processo de construção
e desconstrução e reconstrução que
significa sanções e pra mim nada mais
importava não será que ela faz
era o único golo da partida incluiu a
tarde era aquela frase
[Aplausos]